we had huge news yesterday which is that
joe biden will get an opportunity to
select the first of we don't know how
many supreme court justices during his
presidency we learned yesterday that
if democrats don't screw it up and
unfortunately i already will have an
example for you today
of a democrat who seems to not
understand the risks here and that this
could end up getting getting screwed up
um 83 year old supreme court justice
stephen breyer plans to retire and as a
result joe biden will get to replace
a liberal justice with a liberal justice
and that is an important factor here in
that this will not change the balance of
the court
but it will ensure that breyer's seat
will stay with
the left the liberals whatever term you
want to apply
um for some period of time that will be
dependent on the age of the person
selected to replace breyer so nbc news
reporting justice stephen breyer to
retire from the court paving the way for
a biden appointment the liberal
justice's decision to step down after
more than 27 years on the court
allows biden to appoint a successor who
could serve for decades biden and breyer
is scheduled to appear together at the
white house today as the supreme court
will announce his retirement that may
have happened by the time you listen to
today's show brian is one of three
briar rather is one of the three
remaining liberal justices his decision
to retire after more than 27 years on
the court allows biden to appoint a
successor who could serve for decades in
the short term maintaining the current
6-3 split between conservative and
liberal justices this is a really
important aspect of this which we're
going to talk about we're replacing a
liberal with a liberal
it doesn't shift the court trump's big
thing
was putting in amy coney barrett to
replace ruth bader ginsburg replacing
a liberal
with a pretty serious conservative now
joe biden previously said he would
appoint a black woman to the supreme
court who would be the first black woman
ever on the supreme court
um it does appear as though that is
still the plan
there has been a short list of potential
nominees released and one of the
uh primary names that really i mean
listen we don't yet know but the person
being mentioned as the front runner
is judge kitanji brown jackson who was
appointed last year to the u.s court of
appeals in washington d.c and so you can
take a look at that short list that is
out there
but d.c circuit judge katanji brown
jackson at the top of the list
california supreme court justice leandra
krueger is believed to be on the list
south carolina u.s district court judge
michelle child on the list and others uh
white house press secretary jen saki
yesterday asked about joe biden's
commitment to putting a black woman on
the court and she had the following to
say go ahead thanks jen two subjects so
let's say hypothetically
a supreme court justice
was to retire and announce it on his or
her own terms
does president biden plan to honor his
pledge to nominate a black woman to the
court well i've commented on this
previously the president has uh stated
and reiterated his commitment to
nominating a black woman to the supreme
court and certainly uh stands by that
for today again i'm just not going to
be able to say anything about uh any
specifics until of course uh justice
breyer makes any uh announcement should
he decide to make an announcement okay
so immediately there is
argument disagreement controversy over
this
there are some on the right who are
saying
this is racism this is racism you are
preemptively saying
i will not consider white people for the
position therefore it's racist to say
we're going to appoint a black woman to
the supreme court
now i think that's a terribly bad faith
argument and i i must give the following
reminder if not disclaimer to the people
who may not be familiar with my view on
identity politics
i am not an identity politics fan
i am against the use of identity as a
cudgel or to silence
or to
elevate
when it comes to
the world
and that being said i recognize that
one's identity can be an interesting and
relevant factor
in
the exploration
of
topics
of all sorts economic social cultural
whatever the case may be
and so for me
these ideas of i will nominate a black
woman they're not super interesting to
me it doesn't i don't like biden more
because he says i will put a black woman
on the court but
i'm now not so deluded as to think
that this would be the same
as saying i will only put a white person
on the court we have a history in the
united states where we had a supreme
court for the longest period made up
exclusively of white men
and a history of enslaving black people
in the united states so
while i am not an identity politics guy
i recognize
that it would be a relevant milestone
for the country
to say hey we've had for hundreds of
years we've had all these different
types of people in the country
and yet we've never had a black woman on
the court now i also would say this is
not only restricted to black women uh
what about native americans what what
about asians
the the point here is we can
simultaneously
be against the toxic destructive
counterproductive identity politics that
i've been criticizing on the program for
a very long time
and recognize that wait a second we've
never had a black woman on the court oh
it would be a relevant milestone to have
one of course starting from the baseline
that there are countless black women who
would be qualified to be on the court
that's another aspect of this that the
wright is being very bad faith about
which is saying
when you say i'm going to put a black
woman on the court that's that's the
that's a category which i'm going to
seek to fill
you are no longer putting qualified
people there you are choosing identity
over qualifications now if there were no
qualified black women in the country
that might be an argument to be made but
of course there are countless qualified
black women to be on the court and so
the idea that we are sacrificing
qualifications for identity it also is
not the case so i i hope that it's
coming through that we can be
reasonable about this
without falling into these very bad
faith arguments that the right is
seeking to make i think the bigger
concern
is
if and how republicans are going to come
up with a way to block this right i mean
i don't know guys we're only nine months
from a midterm maybe it's too soon to be
confirmed shouldn't the people have a
say or maybe omicron or cancel culture
there must be some reason republic you
know if if briar announces the
retirement today
when the when the retirement is
announced on a thursday
during winter in the northern hemisphere
marjory taylor green gets to pick
instead of biden i'm obviously kidding
but
they may try to figure some way
to try to block this now one other
aspect of this is that on the identity
piece
other presidents have done the same
thing just to be thorough on that
remember when donald trump said this and
none of the republicans went crazy
i will be putting forth the nominee next
week it will be a woman
wow
and the crowd cheered for that it was
okay when trump said it's going to be a
woman or remember this this was this was
uh ronald reagan this is tom brokaw who
remembers this one
ronald reagan today promised to appoint
a woman to the supreme court if he's
elected president whoa
hold isn't that
isn't that identity poli
they're they're total hypocrites they
didn't care when trump did it okay fine
we know that um next thing
i can imagine in all seriousness not
wanting
a seat at the current supreme court
table let me explain what i mean
we have a hyper partisan court right now
we have a court that at 6 30
is making rulings
obviously based on partisan politics and
not
simple sober interpretations of the law
the court is a 6-3 majority right now
for the conservatives and it will remain
a 6-3 majority once breyer is replaced
with whoever joe biden nominates
i'm not sure i would even want to be
part of a court
where my opinion would almost literally
never matter if you had a 5-4
conservative court
with justice roberts who has sided with
liberals in the past
it leaves the possibility that when you
put in a black woman to be part of some
votes that will have an impact and make
a difference there is no chance of that
for as long as this is a 6-3 court now
i'm not literally saying whoever is
nominated should turn it down
but i could understand why a nominee
might think you know it might be better
for my legacy not to be nominated right
now
uh just just a thought that i'm having
and of course if the person is young
enough
they could be appointed they could be
confirmed now
in this kind of futile 6-3 situation and
down the line circumstances change and
they end up being part of some impactful
decisions last thing republicans are
also now pulling this uh
is joe biden going to get rid of the
problematic kamala harris
by putting her on the court here's peter
alexander asking about that there
ginsberg none of that you can share i'm
not going to detail internal planning
from here no okay then let me ask you a
couple other questions is there any
scenario in which the president would
select his vice president kamala harris
for the supreme court
again i'm not going to speak to any
considerations preparations lists
and as we've stated earlier and you
heard the president say it is there's a
long history of supreme court justices
determining when uh they may retire and
then so because gensake didn't rule it
out then peter ducey followed up about
the same thing and then it becomes a
story that uh it's like a runaway train
talked about isn't an initial package
okay thank you good thank you when you
were asked about the vice president
possibly being selected as a supreme
court nominee you said you're not going
to speak to any considerations does that
mean she is being considered
again peter i'm not going to speak to
the reports of a supreme court justice
retirement that hasn't been announced
so um and then fox news was talking
about this and it took on a life of its
own absolute last thing on this
democrats might still screw it up
and
there is a tweet that exemplifies this
from jennifer habercorn quoting senator
dianne feinstein apparently senator
dianne feinstein doesn't see a rush to
confirm a briar replacement saying with
six months until justice breyer departs
the court the senate judiciary committee
will have ample time to hold hearings on
president biden's nominee
i really hope that they don't take all
of that time because that's exactly how
you get into a situation that allows
republicans to say now it's rushed now
it's right before an election we can't
do this don't do it democrats please
don't screw it up
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that i
want every day i don't always have time
to get exactly what i want from the
foods i'm eating but that's why athletic
greens ag-1 is so great it's a solution
that gives you everything in one scoop
and you get 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals as well as probiotics so it
supports gut health
it is one of the great sort of add-ons
to having proper balanced nutrition
athletic greens ag-1 has become a
regular part of my day i'll put it in a
smoothie it tastes great sometimes i'll
just drink it by itself and it's been a
really great and convenient way to get
everything i would get from a
multivitamin and minerals and probiotics
that i might otherwise take separately
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase when you go to athletic
greens.com pacman the link is down below